scp-682 vs scp-2855  they say that money makes the world go  round but can mr money put the reptile  underground  scp-2855 or mr money is part of dr  wondertainment's little mr series his  ability is having whatever capabilities  his buyer believes he has so he was sold  to a member of the o5 council as a man  who can permanently destroy  scp-682 and will do so immediately upon  completion of this transaction however  this didn't happen instead he  disappeared for an hour during which  time as cp 682 seemed to show no ill  effects he later reappeared next to the  council member dazed in experiencing  memory loss with a note that read oops  doctor one detainment offers the  sincerest of apologies for this  unanticipated malfunction of your mr  money tm we will be working to correct  this error in future products goodbye